Did you think you might actually be trying to look cute today, I'm wearing sweatpants everything's a lie
Hi guys my name is Grace Helbig if you did not know, now you know your life is different now.
This is a video that I just kind of wanted to do I feel like a popular Halloween costume this year is gonna be one of Taylor Swift's looks from
Look what you made me do I thought, I liked that music video
I want to try to DIY a couple of the looks from that music video to prove that anyone
Can do it literally if I can do it anything can do it like a, stump
can do it. I want to try and do two looks from the music video the first one
I'm thinking might be kind of easy knock on wood
That's not how you knock there. You go. The first look. I'm gonna attempt to make on my own is this one
Whoa?
sexy
WWE male wrestler hairstyle meets a dominatrix furry bathing suit from the 20s
I went to like Nordstrom Rack and TJ Maxx and found some
Pieces of clothing that I think I can transform into these looks
So let's just do it! Look what you made me do Taylor you made me make a video that I actually enjoy doing how dare you. I super lucked out at Nordstrom Rack
And I found this bodysuit that already has flouncy sleeves like what Taylor looks like except
It's not furry but  f*** it. This was 30 bucks, and it has a v-neck at the front
And hers is a high neck so I figured I'm just gonna wear it backwards
She has the words rep R E P 'cause reputation
Woah, then I found that I have this iron on transfer paper
Yes, what ta f*** da
I have silver exactly like what she has. Gonna try and just freehand
These letters as best as I can and then we're gonna cut them out and iron them on. Oh this feels very fragile
I'm gonna have glitter all over me for possibly the rest of my life cuz this is herpes. Oh boy
This is hard to do. I can't do it. It feels weird to just be staring at Taylor's tits
She is no idea, not the first one. Sure that's good enough
Can't see what I'm doing. Way to f*** this up
Okay, okay sort of and now we cut it out. Oh boy. Oh boy
Also, I want this to actually turn out okay
So this might be my Halloween costume this or sexy boy from stranger things. No, saying that out loud
I veto that. I can't that see my lines, sweet Jesus. We have an R
C'mon cut the middle, goddamn it
RE now let's do this P. Oh, how do people make anything where did the P go?
Oh no, they all look like they could be P's I got layers in the P up
Okay there we go we have our REP now, I'm gonna get my iron
great conversationalist, so we have our iron set to
hot. I just kind of take a cardboard that the paper came in and put it in between
So we're gonna place our letters. I'm gonna fix up this P looks bad. Okay, stop touching it stop touching the P
penis. So this says to put a cloth over it and then apply the heat we can do it, we hot
I have a P now? We can do it, we can do it, we can do it. I'm so bored
I don't know how long you're supposed to do this for any time I iron letters on a t-shirt, which I hardly ever do
I try and go way longer than what the directions say because directions always underestimate how bad I am at
creating things. Oh no they're not sticking. No! unless they need to just be iron more I just need to be more patient
Smells like burning. Um so let's have some small talk shall we
Ants
Small talk- okay, let's let this sit for a second plus some more seconds. I just want to be done
How about some more small talk?
um
biggie
Okay, oh my god. Oh my god it worked
Look at that!
That's pretty f*** good. I don't toot my own horn very much, but toot toot, excuse me you can be kind of done
just like this but it's a high-neck
situation and I love a good high neck. High neck, low expectations
I have gone and got some of these like lace pieces. Just hot glue a little bit here and a little bit here
Just in the front, so let's do that
Ouch, ouch why do I keep touching you!
Okay, I'm gonna let that dry well that dries-
Oh f*** come on. In the meantime her makeup's pretty basic other than a signature red lip which
Bam slam dunk
and now we're gonna try and do our hair like her which is just sort of messy and
Back, and wet I've been doing a bunch of spring-cleaning fall-cleaning winter-cleaning
I don't know, times an illusion
And I just threw away a bunch of old hair gel that would have been perfect for this. I have hair spray and some boys
Pomade let's see what we can do with this it, just going for it
what the f*** is this s****
Ouch, this is not what I ouch, what I should be using oh ouch, ouch
Okay, it's like curly flap behind her ear pin it. This pomade is the worst idea ever sorry Brooks
The beauty is suffering
okay, I think that's pretty decent enough the other thing is this guy's a little bit higher on the hips than what she's got a
little bit of a low rider so I got these black
I got these little black Spanx that I'm gonna put over it and see what they look like if it makes sense
Let's change into our first Taylor Swift  look what you made me do, what? just cut to the next f*** thing
Oh look what you made me do, look what you made me do
Look what you just made me, look what you just, ouch
Ah you guys this turned out f*** great
I'm shocked at how well this turned out and I am the first one to acknowledge when I've done
s***
'cause I make a lot of s***, just part of who I am
What do you guys think? If you make anything like this you get to wear Spanx!
It just feels like a gentle hug around your ovary. Okay. Let's move on to the next one wow that was a journey
I'm feeling good which only means one thing. S***'s probably about to hit the fan. The other look
I'm gonna try recreate is the very opening Taylor Swift look
The Zombie Taylor Swift look. I've never done my own zombie makeup before but I thought
Why not now?
No, that's not what I thought. I thought I really want to make tacos for dinner, and I did I did that at t.j.maxx
I got this blue long sleeve thing for like $10 on clearance half of its done
So now it's time to do a zombie makeup. I'm not gonna look up any tutorials
I'm just gonna look at a photo of zombie Taylor, and wing it. Yeah this is intense
I'm not gonna be able to make it look like that. Let's beat the face until it's dead it's also already
11:15 at night so for this look her whole body zombied out
I'm just gonna do the head how many references to giving blowjobs and touching wieners can I have in this video?
I have this look children's face paint, and I have a sponge brush
Oh, I'm just gonna slop it on Wow who came up with the first idea of like face painting for kids parties
Oh, it's like the creepy pervert adult that was like children come here. Let me touch your faces with
Paint brushes. Bend it into the neck and give it some texture zombie skin does not
moisturize. Mix some white and black to get like a grey just some general outlines of cheekbones again
we're not pros. We're just desperate for attention
Just blending all that in. Okay now
I have smaller paintbrushes that I guess I'll just see if I can get any detail going
Green going in there too. Bob Ross your face out
The thing is about building layers, like a relationship
Sort of morphing into a ninja turtle anymore white and black on the lips I could look like they should have been  chapped
F*** s**** for years, which is story of my living life. Oh, I like turtles
I mean, that's as good as I think we're gonna get on this mine looks a little bit more colorful than hers
We all age differently We all die differently her hair is gross which is great cuz that's how mine feels right now
So I'm just gonna take it out. Yeah pomade you're back in the game. You're made for this kind of hairstyle
Oh, I feel beautiful. Let's put our outfit on and see how close we look to zombie Taylor Swift
Look what you made me do what you made me do what you just made me do look what you just made me do
oh look what you made me do
Have I found the one thing that I might be good at? Just recreating
looks from Taylor Swift music videos?
This is pretty good
I think, I mean obviously if I was doing this for Halloween I'd do my arms and the rest of my body
But I don't love you guys that much I shredded the bottom a little bit and use that to cinch this part up here
She has on her dress to me
This is another successful Taylor Swift look what you made me do Halloween DIY
Or just do you know if you wanna  f*** with your friends, your loved ones, your enemies, your pets. We did it!
Well there you go that was my attempt to make DIY
Taylor Swift from the look what you made me do Halloween costume amazing how it turned out, right?
I don't know because I'm shooting this outro before I even attempt to make the costumes cuz I'm lazy if you like lace and just
Give this video a thumbs up and please subscribe to this YouTube channel
I make videos Monday Wednesday and Friday click that Bell notification
So you know when this of this quality quality content?
Comes out other than that. I don't know
You guys want to see my zombie walk her we go. Oh look what you mean me -
What you mean me - what?